only on CBS this morning the CEO of
jewel labs is defending his company's
reputation amid growing concerns and
mounting lawsuits tied to vaping jewel
markets itself as an alternative to
traditional cigarettes and the
e-cigarette giant says its mission is to
improve the lives of the world's 1
billion adult smokers by eliminating
cigarettes and the goal appears to be
paying off in recent weeks cigarette
sales volume declined more than 7% that
is more than twice the historic rate of
decline and according to a report
released this month by Wells Fargo east
cigarette sales led by Joule are a major
reason for that decrease
jool CEO Kevin burns told us why he
thinks that's great news is it true you
track cigarette sales every Friday and
compared medjool sales every Monday at
9:00 a.m. 9:00 or 1:00 a.m. page 3 on
the Nielsen report I go right to page 3
cigarette declines for the week you're
on your cigarette declines that's the
first number I look at you want to see
them going down wanna see them going
down double-digit rates is our objective
so you think Joule is killing the
American cigarette I think Joule is
absolutely contributing to the decline
in the smoking rate in the United States
as our share of the cigarette industry
is grown in the US we've seen a high
correlation decline in the smoking rates
the United States we're at three times
the historical average in terms of the
decline rate of cigarettes being smoked
in the United States fair to say you
think you're safer than cigarettes I'm
not gonna comment about where I am in
terms of that cigarettes are here the
patch is here jewel is in the middle
let's just say cigarettes are known to
be the number one source of preventable
death in the world and are at the far
end of the stream the continual risk in
2020 may you have to file with the FDA
and prove to them that you are a net
good for public health correct that's
taking into account underage use and
that's taking into account the potential
benefit for adults do you think you can
meet that threshold that jewel is a net
good for public health we think so you
feel confident yeah we think so the FDA
will be the final judge and arbiter on
that but we think so yes
yet Jewell points out the FDA limits
what it can say about potential public
health benefits
one point following an exchange about
product safety the jewel team had to
break from our interview to determine
what they could and couldn't say so what
are your studies that you're gonna file
in just 10 months what are they telling
you about the the health or safety of
the vapor when people inhale it again I
can't give you a relative health that
way again we've restricted the FDA won't
like restricted we've tested we do
toxicology testing on all of our product
people say jewel is toxic is it the
product of the company interesting that
you would you would ask the product we
toxicology test all of our products so
when people say the long-term effects of
vaping are not known that's true that's
true that's a true statement and how do
you sit here and sell it every day
aren't you selling first and asking
questions later we think we have a
product that is legal today is tested
for toxicity and does not present a risk
based on the guidelines of the category
today to the American public but fair to
say if you knew this to be a toxic or
dangerous substance you wouldn't be
selling it I can't imagine we had the
data to support that we're selling a
product that is damaging to the American
public and we had that data that we
continue to sell that product the reason
I have to ask is because the tobacco
industry doesn't exactly have a great
track record when it comes to telling
the truth and the American people about
what they're selling can you understand
why people might find it hard to trust
you because you're also selling nicotine
sure sure it's a lot of it's a lot of
Association that comes with that in
terms of being in the nicotine business
sure I understand it and our job is to
create the right kind of protocols do
the right kind of tests publish the
right kind of research make sure it's
peer-reviewed deliver it in a
transparent fashion and over time
hopefully build some credibility in
terms of that it's going to take a while
though to build that credibility did it
hurt your credibility to take billions
of dollars from Altria the sellers of
Marlboro quintessential big tobacco
company certainly hurt us in the I would
say in the health and scientific
community certainly hurt us and why do
it we had lots of internal debates on
this in terms of the pluses and minuses
associate with this so this was not you
know something where there was you know
no downside
in terms of perception or reputation or
affiliation socially but we understood
that so the plus is the billions of
dollars and the downside is public trust
I think there's a lot more pluses in
that today listen I make my most most of
my rationale for this is that they're
gonna help accelerate our mission I've
got access to retail space that I
wouldn't have otherwise I have access to
research that I wouldn't have otherwise
I have access to their 17 million smoker
database that it wouldn't have otherwise
that I can target smokers very
specifically and know that I'm talking
to people that are adult smokers I have
access to all their scientific
information related to pmta that they
can be helpful on so there's a lot of
pluses in terms of fulfilling our
mission that would go well beyond any
financial contribution you ever run into
parents who think you're just a blood
sucking device industry I see parents
all the time who are not fans of the
company and not fans of folks that work
at the company what do they say to you
we can't talk on camera in that way in
terms of some of the really it's like
it's that kind of it's an emotional
topic and I understand it the data I was
looking at recently shows it's not only
former smokers that you're converting
some people are starting jewel and
they've never been on nicotine before
what's your advice to those people don't
don't they don't use jewel don't start
using nicotine if you don't have a
pre-existing relationship with nicotine
don't use the product you're not our
target consumer and Kevin burns even
went on to say he making money is not
his number-one priority right now it is
getting through that FDA process and see
you're skeptical he thinks he can
convince the health officials and the
country that they are a net good for
public health I hand it to him for even
doing an interview with you when vaping
and jewel or certainly under attack and
being heavily criticized the fact that
hey you gave him a lot of time to
certainly tell his side of the story and
he didn't shy away from anything that
you asked him I applaud that
especially during this time yeah no
absolutely and and by the way Julie is
going to help pay convenience stores to
install that age verification technology
so it should be rolling trying to make a
difference yes